SPEAKER: I'm very excited to
introduce the one and only
Leaf Peterson talking about the
Dart's type system, a subject
near and dear to my heart.
LEAF PETERSON: It's the
type theory talk for today,
it's the only one.
OK, how's the volume?
Is it good?
Sounds like it.
If I'm yelling at
you too loud, sorry.
So Sound Dart.
What's all this about?
So about a year
and a half ago, we
started looking into how
we could layer a sound type
system on top of the
existing Dart language
and Dart type system.
The reason that we did
this kind of crazy thing
was to enable us to improve
the developer experience
with the Dart dev compiler.
That's going to the
next talk, so I'm not
going to talk about that a lot.
This talk is about what
we call strong mode, which
is the sound type
system that we designed.
I want to talk about what
it is, what it does for us,
and how it can make your lives
as Dart developers better.
So going to start out by
talking a little bit about what
soundness is in general.
I think in some ways
this is obvious,
but I think it's
really worth talking
about what the core of soundness
is when we come down to it.
So really, soundness
is about a relationship
between the programs that you
write, the code that you write,
and the values that show
up in the code at runtime.
So we say that a type,
system or language,
is sound if whenever you say
that something is a dog, when
your type system says this
expression, this piece of code
has static type dog,
everything that you get out
at runtime in that
position is going
to be a dog and nothing else.
So if I write some code
like this, for example,
I think it's pretty clear
what the intent of this is.
I'm saying I'm going
to feed the dogs,
and my intent is to
pass it a list of dogs.
So I've written
the type list Dog
to say, hey, this
code should take dogs.
So if I were to come
along and read this code,
I might very reasonably
act under the assumption
that all of the things that
reach the variable fido
are going to be a dog.
And that's a good thing, right?
So Fido probably going to
have a feed method, and fido
will probably very be very
happy to get a juicy bone there.
So that's very reasonable
as a programmer
I've expressed my intent.
And if I'm refactoring
I might come along
and act under the assumption
that the things that
are going to get here are
going to be a list of dogs.
But in fact, in regular
Dart, even in checked mode,
there's no guarantee that
the things that show up here
are actually going to be dogs.
I might get a number,
or I might get a string,
or I might get something
completely unexpected.
So despite the intent,
we're not living in a world
where things that are
claimed to be dogs
will necessarily be dogs.
In regular Dart, you
might get something
completely unexpected
in a place where
you expected to get a dog.
There's lots of reasons why
you might care about soundness.
The one that I
want to start with
is why soundness matters to us
as people implementing Dart,
and so I want to talk
about compiling first.
So when you're
compiling unsound code,
you have to be very cautious
about what things might show up
where you expected a dog.
This isn't a real problem
for a VM, for a just in time
compiler, because a just
in time compiler can
make optimistic assumptions,
and then later on it
can change its mind.
It can say, oh, I got a cat.
I will recompile this
code, patch it back in,
and everything's good.
So we can do the really
fast thing optimistically
and change its mind later.
When you're in an
ahead of time compiler,
you have to actually
plan for the worst case.
You need to deal with all of
these different possibilities
statically.
You need to worry
about what happens
if it doesn't have
a feed method,
or if it has a feed
method which expects
different sorts of parameters,
or it has a feed setter
or getter or something.
So all of those
things are things
that can possibly
happen at runtime,
you need to be
prepared for them.
So that makes your
code much bigger,
it makes it harder to
generate readable code
if you're in the ahead of
time compilation setting.
So the original goal,
The original motivation
of looking at the
sound type system
is to enable a
better ahead of time
compilation system to give a
better developer experience so
that we could very quickly
generate very readable code
that you could very easily debug
on any browser that you wanted.
And we're going to talk more
about that in a little bit.
So if you are working
with a sound language
and you're compiling
this code, you
don't now have to worry
about very unexpected things.
You don't have to
worry about strings,
you don't have to
worry about numbers,
you can just assume
you're going to get a dog.
Everybody likes dogs.
Now when we came out
with strong mode,
some people just turned out
to kind of like strong mode
anyway.
So even some people
who are not actually
using the technology
that we're building
over strong mode started
turning on strong mode
because they found the things
that we were building into it
were useful to them as
developers, as well.
Flooder was one of
our early customers,
and they were a
super useful one.
Because they gave us lots
of really good feedback,
but they were not actually
using the technology that we
were building into this.
And we saw this a
lot where people
were using strong mode
to get the benefits just
of the stronger type system.
And so strong mode
is now, I think,
expanding to being used more and
more for these other benefits
we're talking about.
So when I'm working with
code, when I'm writing code,
when I'm reading code,
when I'm maintaining code,
those are all situations
where having reliable types
also can provide some benefits.
So if I'm reading code, it's
OK to sort of assume that
when the user wrote a list of
dog that that was their intent,
and that's what it will be.
But it's a little unsafe.
You could be relying on
accidental properties
of the code that aren't actually
tracked by the type system.
And this is even bigger
when you go around
and you start incrementally
modifying code.
If you don't get the feedback
from the type system,
it's harder to maintain
very large amounts of code.
And Google has large
amounts of code.
So our goal was that
all these people
who are doing all this work
to write types in their code
would get all of the
benefit that they really
weren't getting.
What we were seeing was that
people were writing this code
as if it was a statically typed
language, as if it was sound,
but they weren't getting
all of the assistance
that they could because
the language wasn't sound,
and the types can lie.
So our motto for strong mode
is that we want to make it
so that the types can't lie.
So what is strong mode?
There's really
three pieces here.
There's a type system, there's
a set of runtime checks
that deals with the remaining
dynamism in the language,
and then there's
some type inference
which are there to keep
the language feeling dirty.
So I want to talk about
each of these three pieces
starting with the
sound type system.
So there's really
actually in some ways
surprisingly little
that we had to change
to make the type system sound.
There are really just
three major things
we had to change about the
way the type system works.
The first is that we had
to change the way override
checking works.
So dog here inherits
from object.
Object has a hashcode
method that is
declared to return an integer.
Standard Dart doesn't object if
you change the return type here
to object, and string is a
perfectly reasonable object.
So this is a perfectly valid
override in normal Dart.
It's a bad idea,
please don't do this.
Strong mode will yell at you,
my cat will look at you funny.
It's a bad idea.
Similarly, covariant
method override.
So that was the return type.
If you want to tighten
the type on a parameter.
So in some ways this looks
like very reasonable code.
So I have an animal, and I say,
well, it's got a chase method.
And the chase method, an
animal chases some animal.
And now I'm going to take
a cat, and it's an animal,
and it will chase the mice.
This seems quite reasonable.
But the problem is that if
I assign a cat to an animal,
I can then send that cat off
to chase a dog, which is going
to make for an unhappy cat.
So strong mode will yell
at you if you do this,
please don't do that.
Another one that I think is
actually surprisingly important
is getting rid of these
sneaky dynamic lists.
So lists, and in general,
all sorts of generics.
When you're working
with generics in Dart,
there's actually a
cool feature of Dart
where you can take a generic,
you can instantiate it
with dynamic, and now you
can use it as anything.
So here I've made
a list of dynamic,
and I filled it with dogs.
This is allowed to
masquerade as a list of cat.
It's kind of a cool
thing, but it totally
breaks all your soundness.
Strong mode will yell at you,
my cat will look at you funny,
please don't do that.
Similarly to the
override case, we also
restrict function
subtyping to be
the usual contravariant on
the parameter, covariant
in the return type.
If you have something
which registers a cat
and expects a callback
which returns a cat.
In regular Dart,
this is assignable.
A function which returns
an animal is assignable.
So you can pass in something
which returns a dog when
you register your cat.
That's not going to
make anybody happy,
strong mode won't let you do it.
Please don't.
So these restrictions
are basically
enough to make a sound
type system, sort of.
So what's the sort of?
We didn't want to
go fully, in part
because we have a
huge corpus of code.
And people like
writing Dart code.
So we don't want to
come along and say,
you are all bad
people and wrong,
and we want to punish you
for writing Dart code.
We want to keep the language
as Darty as possible.
So one of the ways we
did that is saying,
OK, there are certain patterns
which are not quite statically
sound, but we can
recover soundness
by injecting runtime checks
sort of like checked mode,
but a very small
subset of checked mode.
So here, for example, is
actually perfectly valid
strong mode code.
Even though this looks
really kind of silly when
you write it this
way, it's actually
pretty reasonable in some ways.
You have something
which is an animal.
It might be a cat.
In this case, though, it
is, in fact, not a cat.
We will statically
let this through,
but we will yell
at you at runtime.
So strong mode has an implied
run time downcast here,
which is going to stop
you from actually putting
a dog where a cat is when you
actually get there at runtime.
So that's the
runtime part of it.
There's also some
checks required
to deal with covariant generics,
we keep generics as covariant.
Which is not totally sound,
but that works for us.
So there's a caveat here
with the runtime checks.
These are only implemented in
the Dart development compilers
so far.
We've had a lot of
success with strong mode
and a lot of success
with the dev compiler.
We are moving towards
implementing these semantics
more widely in our tools and
supporting them more broadly
so that you can
make use of them.
But so far you're only going
to get those runtime parts
of the checks when
you're actually running
in the Dart dev compiler.
So that means that you can
actually break our type system,
in a certain sense,
if you're using
one of the other platforms.
But you still get the benefit
of the static checks anyway.
And if you're running
in checked mode,
you actually get most
of those checks as well.
The last piece I want to
talk about is type inference.
And this is the really
cool part, I think,
because this is a
part where we give you
a whole lot of benefits.
And it's also the
part where we do
things to make working with
the stronger type system still
feel very Darty.
So in regular Dart, when
someone writes var-- like here
they say var fluffy,
what that actually means
is that the type of
fluffy is dynamic.
So that's a little
surprising in some ways.
A lot of people think
of this as saying,
this is maybe type inference,
or I don't know what.
But really it means dynamic.
And what that means is
that if I do something
like this, where I take
a substring of fluffy,
this is perfectly valid code
in regular Dart statically.
Because it's dynamic, and
dynamic has all methods.
So we changed that
in strong mode.
In strong mode Dart,
saying var means
please infer for a type
for me here rather than
just treat this as dynamic.
So when you write
code like this,
we will infer a type of
cat for that variable,
and we will yell at you.
It's not just var,
basically any place
that you leave off a type
in code in strong mode,
we will try to fill in a type
for you using type inference.
So here I have a map literal
and a string inside of a list.
These, in regular
Dart, are interpreted
as dynamic lists
and dynamic maps,
so you could have lots of stuff
in here that you didn't expect.
Or you could add
something later on
and you would get no
checked mode errors
because the type of these
things were actually at runtime,
or are dynamic.
In strong mode, we will actually
push down this outer type
into this term here.
And we'll say,
OK, because you're
saying that x is supposed to
be a list of maps from string
to ints, this is
clearly going to be
a list of maps from
string to ints,
and this map is going to
be a string to int thing.
So statically, we
figure this out,
and then we set that
type in runtime.
And now any checks
later on, if you
were to add something which was
not a map from string to ints,
we could give you a
runtime check mode error.
Similarly, if you
override a method-- here
we have animal, which is
overriding the two string
method-- and you leave off
one of the types, we'll say,
OK, the superclass already
declared this method
with a type so we will
infer a type for you.
Even more interesting, if we
have a big composite expression
like this, we can push types
all the way through this
to get lots of interesting
type information.
Which is just super
useful, and I'll give you
an example of this in a minute.
So here we can come
along, we can say, look,
this is the list,
you put a cat in it.
We'll infer that this
is a list of cat.
That means that, well,
the parameter to map
is going to be cat, because
I'm coming from a list of cats.
And that means that the
things that I'm returning here
from c.owner are
people, and that
means that this variable is
going to be a list of person.
I can infer all
that for you, and I
can give you error messages
and completions based on that.
So the goal is to be sound
but still very terse.
So we really wanted to
keep the Darty feel,
and we really wanted
to keep the ability
to write code that had all
the nice things about Dart
but still was sound.
And I think so far I've
been really happy with how
this has worked out.
We have a very
large corpus of code
that has been converted
to strong mode,
and it's actually
really pleasing
how small the changes are
in a lot of the cases.
And that's actually been
hugely valuable for us
as people designing
this type system
is that we have a
huge amount of code
to learn about what
actually matters.
And one of the
reasons I really like
that is that that's
allowed us to stay very
simple with our type inference.
We've very deliberately
chosen to stay
in the subset that is
very fast to compute
and is very predictable.
Doesn't tend to have the sort
of spooky action at a distance
that you get sometimes with
stronger type and inference
algorithms.
But we can still cover most of
the common cases that actually
matter in practice
just by looking
at a little regional
piece of code.
So this is super exciting, and
we're still improving on this.
I think it's really cool.
So I wanted to show you
this actually in action.
Because I think it's really nice
to see how this is integrated
into the tool system.
So what's that?
AUDIENCE: Can you zoom in a bit?
LEAF PETERSON: I can try.
Let me try.
How are we looking there?
Yeah, that's getting better.
OK, so let's work with that.
So here's a simple
hierarchy of types here.
We have people with
a name, we have
an animal with an owner,
which is a person,
and we have cats and
dogs extending animals.
And now I want to do a
few things with my cats,
and dogs, and animals.
So if I start out
with strong mode off,
there's actually no errors
in this code right now.
Let me get us back in to
restart our analysis here.
So there are no
errors in this code.
And if I come along here, so
this is my example from before.
I'm making a list of cats,
and I'm mapping over it.
And now I want to
put a lambda in here.
So one thing that you
can see right away
is that if I try to get a
completion on this variable c,
I'm not going to
get any suggestions
other than the
things on the object.
And the reason for
that is that if you
look at what the analyzer
thinks about map, all it knows
is that it takes a closure
from dynamic to dynamic.
So all it knows about
c is that it's dynamic.
So I might make a guess
as to what I want here.
That looks right to me.
And I don't get any
complaints here,
and I still don't get any
useful completions out
on the other end either,
which is kind of a bummer.
But fortunately, it's
very easy to fix this.
So if I enable strong
mode, and I come in here,
and I reanalyze my code, voila.
I get a nice error message
telling me in very small print
that monkey boy is not
defined for the class cat.
So that's really pretty cool.
And you can actually
poke around in here
and see all the pieces of how
this is getting figured out.
So if I go up to here to
owner, in the regular Dart
this is declaring a variable
field, which is dynamic.
I can look at this now and I
can see that actually we've
inferred a type here for person.
And using that, when we come
down here and fix this code--
so if I look at c here, I can
get completions for owner here.
And the reason is that when
I look at the type of map,
the analyzer has been
able to figure out
that this is expecting a
function from cat to person
now, and it's going to
return an iterable of person.
So again, using
that same process
of starting at the
list, and saying,
OK, this is a list of
cats, pushing that types
all the way down.
We're able to get types
all the way through there.
And now if I come out
to the other end here,
I can actually now get
completions for name,
for example, as well.
All using type inference.
It's super cool to
see it in action,
and I'm really excited to see
more integration into the IDs.
I think we can get a
lot of benefits here.
I want to show one
more small demo.
I really like this one because
this is an example of stuff
where even code that
is very well tested
can have latent bugs in
it that you wouldn't catch
without something
like strong mode
so this is a similar
hierarchy here.
I have animals,
cats and dogs, and I
have some API, which returns
an interval of animal.
And the interesting thing
here is that in practice it
actually returns a list.
But its contract just says
that it returns an iterable.
Now, unfortunately this
is right on the line here,
but if you write code
that calls this API
and then call the add method
on the thing you get back,
you're not going to get any
errors in the regular analyzer.
And you're also
not actually going
to get any errors in your code,
even if you test it very well.
Because in fact, this API
satisfies a stronger contract
than what it declares,
and you are now
relying on that contract.
So you are more tightly
coupled to this code
than you may have intended.
And we actually found
these latent bugs
when we were converting
code to strong mode.
If you go over here and
you re-enable strong mode,
you will actually
get an error saying,
hey, you said that my
animals return an iterable,
and you're trying
to use it as a list.
You might want to fix that.
I was really
excited to see that.
You can play with us now in
IntelliJ, you can use DartPad.
You can just turn on strong mode
with a little button down here.
I don't know if any of the
other stuff that's out there-- I
saw someone using a
visual code thing,
I don't know if
you can use that.
Oh, awesome, that's
what I like to hear.
AUDIENCE: And also,
the CLI looks,
you [INAUDIBLE] these options,
[INAUDIBLE] analyze it.
LEAF PETERSON: That's right.
So certainly if you use the Dart
analyzer from the command line,
you just pass --strong,
and you're good to go.
So I pulled a little bit
of a fast one on you there.
If you're looking
closely, there's
some funky stuff going on here.
What's this parameter to map?
So one of the things that
was missing from Dart when
we tried to go to
implement strong mode
was generic methods.
And that's actually
really important
if you want to track
types around reliably.
Because otherwise your
functions like map,
they lose type information as
soon as you flow into them.
So any time you add composite
expressions like this,
you tended to lose
all of your types.
So generic methods were
added to strong mode first.
So I should have
put this one up.
Here's the regular definition
of the iterable class.
This isn't quite how it's
defined, but you get the idea.
It returns an iterable,
it takes in a function
which just returns dynamic.
In strong mode, we added via
comment syntax generic methods
so that you could
declare this as having
the kind of expected
generic type
where you tell it
the return type
and get back out an iterable
of the appropriate type.
And with type inference we
could basically insert this,
and you didn't even really
have to change the way you're
using it most of the time.
Comment syntax, bad.
So I'm very happy
to say that we're
very close to being able to
fully enable the full syntax.
We're putting generic
methods into the language.
So people have been hard
at work integrating this
so that your code will
work with regular mode
or with strong mode.
And I'm really happy
to see this happening.
It's a thing.
So just a brief mention of
some stuff that's coming.
We're still working really
hard in strong mode,
trying to make it better.
Taking feedback from
people and looking at code.
There are some
knobs we're adding,
and we're going to keep
experimenting, seeing what
are the best ways to
tighten the system,
or maybe to support
more dynamic-y code?
So we're still
working on that stuff.
Generic methods are coming.
We've been experimenting with
supporting covariant override.
So I gave you that example
of the cat chasing a mouse,
and said, that's bad code.
But there's actually
some very valid use cases
for code like that.
And so we'd like to try and
find a way to make that work,
and were experimenting
with that.
We also have some
non-nullability experiments.
Yeah.
Love to see this
happen, we hope we
can make this integrate nicely
into a nice Darty language.
So this is the thing.
It really is a thing.
So this is really
widely used in Google.
We have a lot of people
converting code to strong mode.
It's growing very
rapidly rapidly.
We're moving packages
externally to strong mode,
and we really encourage you
to make new code strong mode
clean.
I think it will make
your lives better,
both in terms of the tooling
that we can provide for you
using strong mode to
bootstrap, but also I
think it'll just
make your life better
in general just
giving you a better
experience with the language.
So give it a try.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.